a new actor is taking the blade but some
people are still thinking of the guy who
started it all Marvel Studios announced
that Maher Sheela Ali will lead a reboot
of blade starring as the vampire hunter
and skilled swordsman Eric Brooks a half
vampire who in the comics is on a quest
to avenge his mother's death people went
wild at the announcement an Academy
Award winning actor breathing new life
into the blade property sounds killer
but wait what about the man Ali is
taking over for in the blade reboot
what's so funny
now that Ali is firmly aboard the
in-development movie it appears that
original blade actor Wesley Snipes is
sunsetting his iconic role for good
however Snipes fans are holding out hope
that Marvel can make room for him in the
blade reboots or else there might be
hell to pay
taking to Twitter one fan suggested that
Marvel should tap Snipes for the role of
abraham whistler blades mentor and
weaponsmith whom kris kristofferson
played in the original blade trilogy as
a way to honor the actor they tweeted
let's start the movement right here
right now for Marvel Studios to cast
Wesley Snipes as Whistler in the reboot
of blade MCU the entire current run of
comic book movies owes everything to the
first blade movie so a little honouring
of the legacy he left isn't too much to
ask another said that no matter how
great Ally is in the role Snipes will
forever be the actor associated with
blade they tweeted Wesley Snipes still
is the baddest blade will ever see in
this lifetime even though the role has
been given to Mahalo Ally in a reboot
special respect to this man
elsewhere fans said that the blade
reboot float won't go over well without
Snipes involved that Snipes quote
deserves a cameo or supporting role in
the movie and that Marvel can go ahead
and cancel the film ahead of time
because they don't want it if Snipes
isn't starring user David W Duggan
argued I think a blade reboot is long
overdue but Mahalo Aldi has his work cut
out if he wants to be cooler as the
character then Wesley Snipes was
meanwhile Dakota Miller said I'm the
biggest blade fan ever and super stoked
about Marvel
bouncing the reboots but if Wesley
Snipes isn't at least in a cameo I'm
gonna riot on the flipside Twitter user
at guava NGO wrote that blade fans
should be more open-minded about Ali's
casting stop focusing so much on the
past and have faith in how Olli will
approach the new iteration of the
character their tweet reads we can
appreciate Wesley Snipes as blade and
also be excited for the reboot you can
have both Wesley Snipes was excellent as
blade ally won't be playing that same
version obviously hopefully he brings
his own style and dynamic to the role
these reactions to Ali's casting his
blade in the upcoming reboot movie may
seem dramatic but they're not all that
surprising
Snipes has long made it clear that he's
ready to return to the role he
originated with 1998 blade a film that
changed superhero movies forever in
December of 2018 the 56 year old actor
took to Twitter to affirm that his teeth
are quote still sharp for a blade reboot
and that it's simply up to Marvel if
they'd like to bring him back on board a
few months later Snipes sat down with
vice and opened up about the possibility
of a fourth blade movie to follow after
Blade Trinity saying there are a lot of
conversations going around right now and
we're very blessed to have the
enthusiasm and interest in something
coming from that world again all the
main execs at Marvel and my team we've
been discussing for the past two years
everyone's enthusiastic about it
everybody gets it but they got a
business to run and they got asked where
the things that they got to figure out
before they can get to it I guess
fast-forward to summer 2019 and it was
reported that Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige was fighting for a new blade
movie with Snipes attached in the lead
role so what happened well Hershel alley
happened the green book and moonlight
actor rang up Marvel Studios and
essentially pitched himself as the new
blade and there was no denying the
powerhouse talent his wish as Feige put
it when rehearsal a calls you answer
that must hurry there's no telling
whether the studio will be receptive if
Snipes says point-blank that he wants a
part in the blade reboot but considering
that the star essentially paved the way
for all superhero actors who came after
him
that his fans are gunning hard for him
to join the new movie Marvel would be
smart to not scream his call someone's
always trying to ice-skate up him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]